was a really bizarre day in politics
yesterday and today last night this is
just such a weird story Democratic
leaders in the House and Senate
respectively Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer they had a meeting with Donald
Trump they went and had dinner with
Donald Trump Pelosi and Schumer come out
of the meeting and they have really
specific claims about what happened in
the meeting and the headlines were
according to Pelosi and Schumer we met
with Trump we came to an agreement on
maintaining daka protections for
dreamers and we came up with an
agreement for a border security package
that specifically excludes funding for
building the wall the immediate reaction
was wow things must be pretty bad
between Trump and Republicans that he's
dealing directly with Democrats and
seemingly giving them a lot of what it
is that they want and you'll remember
when Steve Bannon was interviewed by
Charlie Rose over the weekend he said
daca will cause civil war in the
Republican Party and my reaction was it
seems to be happening if Trump is dining
with Dems and saying let's keep daca and
let's exclude funding for the wall and
my reaction was okay Trump is still an
incompetent clown who's in way over his
head who has no real hard and fast
political philosophy to speak of but I
think keeping dr. protections is good
for the country the wall is a bad idea a
deal to exclude funding for the wall is
good but of course I was wondering how
can someone even really justify this if
you're a supporter of Trump how do you
support a guy who caves so easily
reportedly according to Pelosi and
Schumer doing the opposite of what it
was he said he was going to do and if
the reports were true it just further
confirmed the guy Trump has no
convictions he has a desire just to make
deals and to be seen as doing things but
he'll cave he'll do whatever other
people want if he thinks it'll get
something signed but here's where it
gets really weird that was last night
right cut to this morning Trump now
seems to be denying that any of it ever
happened Trump went on Twitter and
basically said the opposite of what
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi claimed
he started this morning by tweeting
Oh deal was made last night on Daka
massive border security would have to be
agreed to in exchange for consent would
be subject to vote that's pretty
specific right
no Dhaka deal strange is it confusion or
is it that Trump did agree to it last
night but Republicans got to him so they
they got him to change his mind not
really clear what's going on but then it
gets even weirder Trump stays on Twitter
and he seems to be a hundred percent on
board with Dhaka all of a sudden just
slightly later this morning
he went back on Twitter and he said does
anybody really want to throw out good
educated and accomplished young people
who have jobs some serving in the
military really they have been in our
country for many years through no fault
of their own brought in by parents at
young age Plus big border security so
it's unclear what plus big border
security means in the context of Dhaka
but that is very Pro Dhaka
it's basically the argument I've been
making about Dhaka and then what about
the deal on the wall remember Nancy
Pelosi saying we came to an agreement
for border security that excludes the
wall Trump also denying what Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi said they're
tweeting the wall which is already under
construction in the form of new
renovation of old and existing fences
and walls will continue to be built that
seems like kind of a backpedal right and
eventually maybe he'll backpedal all the
way to listen we kind of have had a wall
for a long time it's called the border
between the u.s. and Mexico and I know
that it's just a line on a map but
that's really the wall you can see it on
Google Maps if you look oh and we're
also gonna be adding a velvet rope and a
security guy black guy with an earpiece
like you see it my clubs
what do I think actually happened here I
think Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer are
not going to come out of this meeting
and just lie and make this up on their
own I think one of two things happened
number one Trump is so difficult to
understand and clueless that Pelosi and
June and Schumer genuinely thought that
Donald Trump made this deal that's
possibility number one
more likely is that Trump did agree to
this stuff and then overnight he was
crushed by Republicans once news broke
and he ended up having to backtrack yeah
I agree with your second opinion there
because I remember just last week Nancy
Pelosi asked Trump to tweet something
about how daca recipients would be fined
for at least six months and he actually
obliged and got a lot of positive media
coverage and then soon after there was
that whole debt ceiling debate where
Schumer and Pelosi met with him in the
Oval Office and he actually took their
deal to extend it three months in which
surprised everyone more positive media
coverage so maybe he thought well you
know this is working well for me I can
continue to do this but after meeting
with them and having dinner and agreeing
to some sort of tentative deal realized
that he's going to face a lot of
backlash from his Republican friends in
Congress and some of those Republicans
were very publicly outraged Steve King
from Iowa said unbelievable amnesty is a
pardon for immigration law breakers
coupled with the reward of the objective
of their crime Breitbart news which is
run by Trump's former chief strategist
Steve Bannon had a headline about
amnesty Don as an amnesty Donald Trump
and what this proves is what I've been
saying all along
number one Trump has no personal
political philosophy to speak of as I've
said beyond self aggrandizement and
greed Trump just wants to be a deal
maker he wants to be liked by everyone
and that's not a particularly good trait
for a President of the United States who
often is being told not slightly
different things by people around him
but diametrically opposed things by
people around him and he needs to be
able to make the decision not that he
thinks will get him the most friends or
the most positive printouts of tweets
that his propaganda team brings him
actually what is going to be best for
the country the guy has no political
philosophy to speak of it does seem like
he just wants to be liked which is
pretty strange because it seems as if he
was just going after his own base of
supporters for so long while the
majority of the country was turned
against him and then when it comes to
making deals it seems like he'll make
deals even when they're not the best
deals for him they're not the best deals
for him they're not the best deals for
his supporters they're not the best
deals for Republicans often they're not
good for Democrats many times they're
not good
or anybody right there just deals this
is what people need to understand it's
just about checking boxes and making
deals it doesn't matter what they do it
doesn't matter who's mad at Trump and
this is where maybe the fact that he's
not a lifelong Republican will actually
be reflected which is if it seems as
though you'll get along with Trump and
you'll say you appreciate the meeting
and you've been able to come to some
kind of agreement the guy will agree to
almost anything and this is why who is
around him is such an important thing
and we're already seeing the influence
of Bannen being out speiser out
scaramouche E all of these clowns out
probably as a result of the appearance
of John Kelly doesn't mean Trump is some
progressive by any means doesn't mean
he's any more competent but we're seeing
a shift in the types of conversations
he's willing to have again just to be
liked and to be able to say he's making
deals discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
read it today's episode is made possible
in part by Blue Sky a binary there are
millions of forex traders around the
world and 80% of them lose money and I
actually have been dabbling in forex
trading since I was like 16 years old
and I've lost some money doing it and
usually when people lose money in this
it is because they either lack the
appropriate knowledge they might be
relying on others auto traders or other
traders they follow instead of
themselves sometimes people get
emotional or take bigger risks than they
should or not understand or follow
proper money management rules and blue
sky binaries education course sort of
helps to mitigate every single one of
those risk factors they're a leading
financial education and tech company
focused on forex they've got senior
trading traders with real trading
experience offering a structured and
self-paced course that you can take
video on-demand online tests one on one
education sessions and access to their
community of traders are all part of
that course david pakman show viewers
and listeners can register right now to
get a free one-week trial at blue sky
binary.com
slash david that includes access to
their training platform and
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics if you want to continue after
that it's 9999 a month you can stop or
resume at any time once again that's
blue sky binary.com /d AV ID